- 6:40 in the morning.
I left DRock back at my
apartment by accident 'cause
I moved up my car 15 minutes.
We miscommunicated
so I got to film this.
If you're not
dreaming big for yourself,
who's doing it for you?
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
- Saba, I've been telling you.
- [Casey] Gentlemen.
(Gary laughs)
- What up, my man?
- Gary, good to see you.
- Good to see you, brother.
- DRock, what's up?
- [DRock] Good to see you.
- [Casey] You guys...
- [Gary] How you doing?
- Good.
- You guys, you awake?
- I'm, am I awake?
Kind of question is that?
- Did you hit the
gym yet this morning?
- No, that I haven't done.
- So we're gonna
do that in Canada?
- No, I'm flying in, right back.
- [Casey] You're
flying back today?
- Yeah, I have stuff tonight.
Like original content.
So my ability to communicate
like things that matter to me
and then I don't
know if you have this but
I have the swipe up.
- Yeah.
- You have it, right?
- I mean that's, you know.
I mean, that's a huge deal.
I'm getting about
10% for fucking 70,
that's insane.
- Yeah.
- But I'm doing it every day
daily like 15 pieces so that
will happen over time but still.
- People see me up
there, they're like, whoa--
- What the fuck?
Exactly.
That being said,
you're still probably
going to be able to hold 50%.
Just two camera
nerds just camera nerds.
- [Casey] Camera nerds.
- [Gary] Camera nerds.
How do you spell camera?
- What's that?
C-A-M-E-R, I don't know.
- How do you spell camera?
- [DRock] C-A-M-E-R-A.
- Yes!
This is a picture of a quote
in Russian to 29,000 reach.
- And 161 comments on that.
- 1,000 likes, I mean
like people really,
the appreciation level is
extremely high and Spanish is
the one I'm really kind
of like paying attention,
like Chinese.
Like the reach is,
I'm only targeting people
in my fanbase.
I'm not running ads even.
This is not discovery, this
is within my own ecosystem.
But the share-ability is so high
'cause so many of these people
have been waiting to be
able to share my content.
The amount of fans you have
that want to share your content.
- Who's translating for you?
- Individuals.
- Amazing.
- Mhmmm.
- Amazing, I love that.
Plus, I love the
inclusivity of it.
- Well that's, just incredible.
93% of them like the second it
happened literally thought they
were Hollywood stars,
moved to Hollywood.
Well, okay.
- [Casey] They literally?
- I mean they
literally moved there.
They literally wanted agents.
They literally
needed to be in a movie.
They literally played it
different and I would tell every
one of them I'm
like this is the game.
("The Journey" by Russ)
We're very late.
I'm just random
hello-ing like crazy on DM.
You get a random hello.
Surprise hello, excuse me.
- [DRock] Do you want to walk?
- No, I don't want to walk.
I want to surprise hello.
Can't walk and surprise hello.
- [DRock] Do both.
- Both.
More, more, more.
Elevator up, DRock.
Look at that shin,
look at that shin.
Great shin.
- [Casey] I show shin.
I show shin.
- He shows shin.
How do you spell shin?
- [DRock] S-H-I-N.
- [Gary] I got it.
Listen, I'm happy about that.
- [DRock] Since when
have you started caring
about spelling though?
- [Gary] I don't.
Surprise hellos, just DMs just
(blows raspberry)
just going fast.
Boom, OneMoneyMakingMitch,
send message, paste.
Surprise hello with a heart.
Just want to thank
everyone for the attention.
Humbled.
Will never forget.
My tummy hurts a
little bit which is rare.
Kids are playing basketball,
I want to beat
their faces in right now.
Film out that window, DRock.
I want people to see these kids.
Show them.
Would not let, I would
not let them score.
We're here, we're pulling up.
- Can I get a selfie with you?
- Real quick, I'm super late.
I'm suppposed to be on stage.
- Alright, man.
- Awesome, man.
Thank you. Thank you.
Hi.
- Hi.
- [Gary] Nice to meet you.
Okay, let's do it.
Awesome, see
you in a little bit.
How's the Q&amp;A setup?
I actually want to do,
based on the audience,
I want to do a lot of Q&amp;A.
- Over here.
- [Gary] Okay.
Backstage now at a
church here in Ontario.
About to hit the stage
hard with serious vigor.
I'm gonna teach you more about
selling and marketing right this
second than anything
you'll learn in any school ever.
- [Man] Thank you.
- What you give with
expectation in return, you lose.
(audience applause)
- [Man] Thank you.
- Jab, jab, jab,
right hook is
give, give, give and too many
people interpret it as take.
Jab, jab, jab,
right hook is
give, give, give and then ask.
And so that's the
cadence, you know,
especially when you're asking
for something as big time as an
internship at Vayner that
has become super competitive,
that's when you got to do your
homework on what the value is.
It's awesome that you can do
a flip and that'd be cool on
camera, feels super selfish.
I feel like you
were gonna win twice.
("The Journey" by Russ)
Let's go.
Awesome man,
yeah, let's do it.
You did?
I'm going through it.
There's like 4,000
emails they're going through.
We'll get to you.
- [Man 2] Alright.
- Awesome, take care, man.
Here's what
I think is teachable.
I think that most people that
are not nice to other people,
are broken inside
and are unhappy inside.
And I think through
real psychological work,
therapy, real self-evaluation,
really hitting rock bottom,
some shock to the system
like taking a year vacation or
getting a divorce or having that
conversation with their father
about that thing that
happened when they were 11.
I mean there's a million things
that I do think
can unlock a dream.
I think they're the hardest
things in the world to do and
I don't take it lightly.
I've not been able to do it so
easily so I don't think it's
easy but I do
think it's achievable.
I think it takes an enormous
amount of self reflection,
acceptance and humility on the
part of the person that's doing
the actions and it takes a
complete reset of who they are
from a hardwiring standpoint
and so I would say yes,
but 99% of people
I don't think will pull it off.
And I mean that, by the way.
It's very hard.
The practicality,
the grind, the work,
the real stuff,
the meat, the potatoes.
Everybody wants the sizzle.
Everybody wants
to write the article
about the billion dollar kid.
The problem is
there's three of them. Right?
And there's hundreds of
thousands of million dollar kids
and there's millions of
hundred thousand dollar kids.
The problem is everybody's
trying to map their behavior to
the three trillion dollar kids
and they'll fail and we need to
take that off the pedestal and
we need to start putting the
pedestal and putting the
people on there who are driving
practicality in reality because
as I'm talking to you I have
enormous fear of what happens
when the economy gets softer
because it's been good for nine
years and that's why everybody's
kind of floating around and
pretending the part of founder.
Those people are going to be
working at Bank of America and
Toyota in five minutes.
So they need to get
practical real fast.
I'd be careful with that.
I would tell you my argument
on this issue is that every
generation has it's
people that wanted attention.
Every generation had
it's people that wanted money.
I think we're very
lazy as a society in
throwing people into groups.
I know plenty of lazy
40-year-olds and 50-year-olds
who always wanted work-life
balance and taking vacations.
I know plenty of 40 and
50-year-olds who wanted one on
one attention and I know
plenty of 20 and 30-year-olds
who want the money.
So, I would say and I know I can
tell by your vibe you're gonna
agree with what I say which is
I spend zero time on the macro
of what's going on in the world
of the current conversation.
It is always one on one.
Meaning what does
that person want right now.
Because guess what?
What DRock wants right
now when he's 29 years old,
25 years old, sorry DRock,
what he wants today is gonna be
different in seven years.
So like not only
is it one on one,
it's one on one within a moment.
So much.
I'll tuck this in.
What's that?
For five minutes.
I know, okay?
You know what's
going on with the car?
Like what time it is?
That guy seemed a little weird.
Cool.
- [Man 3] Alright.
- [Gary] Good. I'll be
with you in a few minutes.
Let me bang this out.
Come with us.
Yeah, and the
last time it was easy.
It was like
going to a Knicks game.
- [Man 4] Gary, oh my God!
(Gary laughs)
Please, we need another one.
- [Gary] Hurry.
You got one second.
You're already too slow.
You ruining the interview.
- [Man 4] We got this,
we got this.
- [Gary] You got
to reverse it, bro.
- [Man 4] Come on, bro,
we got this.
- [Man 5] Take 15 seconds.
- [Gary] Alright, let's do it.
- [Man 5] If you need to tap out
because I know you've
got a plane to
catch and I don't.
- I just want people
to know they've got time.
Way too many
55-year-olds think it's over.
Especially because we live in
this tech world where it's all
about the 20 and
30-year-olds like never before.
I mean you just have time.
I think I said this to you,
and I'll say it to all of you,
when I look at all these young
faces you have so much time.
Like, fuck, I'm 41 years
old and I feel like I'm 7.
I feel like I'm just starting.
I'm like okay,
now the foundation.
You know?
People are 33 and have two kids
and find themselves in a job and
they're like fuck, what?
You have time.
And you're in control.
And I just want people to
realize they have one life
because that's practical.
That's true.
That's actually,
unless somebody,
and actually listen,
if you can prove to me
otherwise I'd be really happy.
Get in here.
Yes, one second,
this man first though.
He's got the Put
In The Work shirt.
Oh, we're doing video.
Go fast.
- Danny at VayerMedia,
I sent him a video.
- Hey Danny.
Take care, bye-bye.
- [Man 6] Safe travels.
- Thank you.
- Hug, thank you so much.
- [Gary] Alright, got to go.
Hurry, hurry, hurry.
Dude, hurry.
I'm gonna miss my
flight for your fucking selfie.
Let's go. No, (laughs).
Let's go.
- [Woman] We're dropping
them off around the corner,--
- Oh, got it, good.
- [Woman] easiest way
for then to say hi to you.
- [Gary] How are you?
- We just wanted to say hi.
- [Gary] How are things, man?
Good to see you again.
- It's great to see you.
- [Gary] Thanks, man.
Was fun. How you doing?
- Good, how about you?
- [Gary] Good.
- You must be really tired.
- [Gary] Not really.
The energy of something
like that is
over the top, right?
- [Man 7] Makes sense.
- Yeah, how've you been?
- [Man 7] Doing well, man.
Really well.
- Good. What's going on?
- [Man 7] Coming
to New York this May.
- What are you going to do?
I know Andy, we were making a
bunch of different decisions.
- [Man 7] Yep.
- [Gary] Do you need
my help otherwise?
Can I help you
in a different way?
- [DRock] You got
your phone, right?
- [Gary] Yeah.
- [Man 7] Just of in terms of
when I go there connecting--
- Connecting.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll help you.
- [Woman] Okay, guys.
- [Gary] Good to see you.
Casey's in there?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- Let's go see him real quick.
Thank you, bro.
Is Casey in here?
- [Man 8] Yeah.
He's in the green room.
- [Gary] Yo, I didn't want to
leave without saying goodbye.
- [Casey] Are you leaving?
- [Gary] Yeah.
I'm missing my flight.
- This is a good prelude
to maybe (inaudible) or
something we got to figure out.
- Yeah, we will.
- Dude, how'd it go out there?
- The love of the
crowd is, you know this.
You're the king of this.
I love it. I love people.
- I'm not the king of this.
You're going back to
New York City right now?
- Right this second.
I'm literally gonna
miss my flight but DRock said
you're back here and I'm like I
got to give him a kiss.
- Don't miss your
flight, thank you.
- I will.
- Thanks for the kiss.
-[Gary] See you later.
- It was good to see you.
- [Gary] Good to
see you, brother.
- David, good to see you.
- [Gary] Bye guys.
("The Journey" by Russ)
Bye, thank you so much.
Alright.
(DRock laughs)
- [Man 9] I said 12:15, Gary.
- I know, my man. I'm sorry.
Alright, we're gonna
be late for this flight.
It's gonna be tight.
- [Man 9] What
time is the flight?
- Three.
We should be okay, right?
We're checked in, right?
- [DRock] We have customs.
- We have customs,
it's gonna be tough.
We'll see what happens.
I mean, yeah,
I just think I can.
I've done really well and I'm
only 41 years old and you know,
I'm not gonna be a
Mark Zuckerberg kind,
a Mark Cuban one big event tons
of money and you know I hope
I stay healthy and my
family stays healthy and,
very frankly, I hope
Woody stays healthy.
I need time. I need time.
("Right Now" by Madreal)
I think I went with a
different kind of vibe.
Mhmmm.
Whatever we have to do to paint
a different picture in your mind
then we'll hack at.
You know,
'cause it's going well.
It really is.
I mean I appreciate
your aspirations but
I can't let them come at the
expense of your mentality.
And that's good,
man, by the way,
by the way, the KPI,
the big win from
this is learning that.
The big win of being in my
inner circle is the thing that
I haven't brought up
a lot lately which is
99% of things don't matter.
- [DRock] I appreciate that
you want to do great things.
- Not at the
expense of your, yeah,
I mean if you out pressure
yourself you're not going to be
able to achieve it.
Like I have the biggest
ambitions of all time but
I'm also extremely comforted in
accepting my short comings and
not everything is
gonna work out perfectly.
The ambition for
perfection is the quickest way
to not achieve perfection.
I strive for what it is.
("The Journey" by Russ)
Not gonna catch me
sleepin' ever again.
So just landed back in Jersey.
And that's fun.
Always like landing in Newark
just a little Jersey love.
Little Holland Tunnel
up in front of us,
love that place.
Anyway, great speech
this morning in Canada.
Hectic, boom, boom.
Little boom, boom, boom.
Little more, more, more.
Casey Neistat spoke after me.
Finally getting his
last name down, DRock.
I'm proud of myself.
Boy, I'm bad at that.
Anyway, Casey's
amazing obviously.
Always fun to be in the presence
of somebody who's got a bigger
social media following than you.
He crushes it on YouTube.
Does his thing.
I saw on social a bunch of
people talking about and quoting
and I forgot and it
reminded me which is
when I invested in his company,
I told him the idea's solid
but very hard to execute.
We'll see but
I'm betting on the jockey,
not the horse.
A lot of you have heard me say
that but this was a successful
investment of mine.
I invested some six-figures into
Casey's company and it returned
when he sold it to CNN
and it solely happened
because of the jockey.
And so, more and more in my life
I'm paying attention to ideas
are fine but it's the people
executing them that
really, really, really matter.
It was nice to
hear him say that.
I'm feeling that the apex.
I feel like I'm entering the
prime of my career as a jockey.
I think these next 20
years are gonna be the best
entrepreneurial
years of my career.
I really do.
'Cause I think at
60 and what have you,
I'll be focusing on the Jets
and family stuff and yeah,
I could just see it changing.
I can feel I'm in it.
I'm excited about it.
And that's humbling
to hear from Case.
Thanks for that Casey and thanks
for all of your guys attention.
I had a lot of
you say today that,
many people said today, multiple
people said today when I was
giving love back and sticking
around for the selfie and
almost missed my flight,
I'm proud to be
giving you my attention.
It just seems like a lot of
you are paying attention to what
matters to me and so
I'm grateful and thankful
and appreciate it and
hope you're enjoying this
journey as much as I am.